it can be so hard to forgive because so
often we simply are in the right and the
scale of the folly thoughtlessness and
meanness of others seems utterly beyond
our own measure but there are two
inviolable ideas which should
nevertheless in the face of the grossest
behavior be kept in mind to increase our
chances of being able to forgive firstly
we must remember how the other person
got there to this place of idiocy and
cruelty every irritating Fault in
another person has a long history behind
it they've become like this because of
flaws in their development which they
did not choose for themselves they were
shaped by troubles troubles which we
cannot see but which we know must exist
the arrogant person was trapped at some
key point in their personal evolution in
an environment where being modest and
reasonable seemed to guarantee they'd be
trampled on the hypercritical individual
has lived too much as their personality
was growing around people who couldn't
take a gentle hint so they came to rely
on blunt assertions the frustratingly
timid mousy person was at some stage
terrified
the show-off learnt they're irritating
manner around people who were hard to
please behind every failing behind
everything that's wrong and infuriating
about those we meet is a decisive trauma
encountered before someone could cope
with it properly they are maddening but
they got to be this way without meaning
to to forgive is to understand the
origins of evil and cruelty secondly and
very strangely there are difficult
things about you too
of course not in this area not in any
area remotely connected to the sort of
lapses that tend to destroy your faith
in humanity but in some areas quiet
areas that you forget about as soon as
you've travelled through them you too
are a deeply imperfect and questionable
individual gently you have in your own
way
betrayed nicely you have been a coward
modestly you have forgotten your
privileges unthinkingly you have added
salt to the wounds of others we don't
need to know anything about you to know
this as a certainty we must forgive
because not right now not over this but
one day over something we will need to
be forgiven we would in the past
regularly have looked upwards to the
heavens for this forgiveness we do that
less and less nowadays but that doesn't
attenuate the need for some moments when
we limber up to utter that most
implausible word sorry or indeed stretch
our ethical imagination in order to
pronounce those even more arduous and
unnatural sounding words I forgive you
the school of life isn't just a YouTube
channel it's an actual school where you
can go and take classes we have branches
in ten locations around the world
to find out more click on the link on
the screen now